[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos al diario de copas de un
espacio diario aquí en france 24 en el
que les vamos a contar la actualidad de
la copa américa y la eurocopa
estos son los titulares de hoy
en la tierra ganó por la mínima croacia
en wembley comenzó con victoria su
camino por la euro desearle y le dio a
los tres puntos a los británicos quedó
en deuda el equipo anti gareth southgate
en su papel como favorito
tenemos análisis
brasil y venezuela dan inicio a la copa
américa más incierta en arena defiende
el título ante un equipo diezmado con
ocho casos positivos de favorito 19
extremos informe desde brasil
unas polémicas declaraciones de james
rodríguez marcan la previa del debut de
colombia frente a ecuador
el delantero dicen que le faltaron al
respeto por no incluirlo en la
convocatoria de la copa
tercer día de la eurocopa de naciones y
comienzo de la copa américa vamos a
estar analizando estas dos competiciones
hasta las finales del 10 y el 11 de
julio y para hacer eso tenemos como
invitada hasta la castro directora del
diario 'as' colombia gracias a la
bienvenida un gusto estar con ustedes
sin duda vamos a tener mucho de que
hablar que discutir porque son dos
torneos muy interesantes y muy esperado
también tenemos a nuestra periodista
natalia ruiz y heraldo desde francia
para hablar el desarrollo de la euro en
su tercera jornada y también a nuestra
corresponsal valere zakone en brasil
para la previa de esta copa américa que
empieza ya este domingo con dos partidos
y vamos a empezar con la euro y los tres
partidos del día victoria por la mínima
de inglaterra ante croacia en el grupo
de ahora mismo está en juego el partido
de austria contra macedonia del norte
por el grupo c y más adelante tendremos
el duelo entre países bajos contra
eugenia por este mismo grupo y para
saber lo último de esta eurocopa vamos
entonces a parís con el informe que nos
envió natalia ruiz
buena entrada en materia para las
elecciones favoritas que ya han jugado
sus primeros partidos en esta eurocopa
hablemos en el grupo de la selección
inglesa que ganó ante croacia un gol por
0 gracias a un gol de sterling los de
white south bay pues dominaron buena
parte de este partido pero hay que
decirles que esta selección se vino de
más a menos sobre todo en el primer
tiempo
en el grupo b tenemos a bélgica
excelente entrada de materia tres goles
por 0 ante rusia una victoria
contundente en gol de men y doblete de
lukaku y roberto martínez que además
pues gana este partido sin contar con
los servicios de kevin de bruyne y
anhela el grupo a pues está italia que
no parte como favorita pero sorprendió
en ese partido inaugural ganando 3 goles
por 0 ante turquía y hay que decirlo
roberto mancini le ha devuelto el buen
fútbol a la escuadra sur a un fútbol muy
vistoso y sobre todo eficaz últimas
noticias de la salud de christian
eriksen el jugador danés que se desplomó
en el partido ante finlandia era el día
de ayer pues el jugador se encuentra
estable en el hospital pero se están
haciendo
bueno sobre todo para saber las secuelas
tras el paro cardíaco que tuvo
ahora en la tierra es sin duda uno de
los dos equipos con el mejor potencial
ofensivo quedó en duda en la tierra
después de hoy de ganar 1-0 ante de
croacia me parece que fue un partido muy
interesante para el equipo de carnet
south gate creo que vimos además de ese
potencial en ataque con sterling florent
con mount y kane creo que también vimos
un equipo que se supo agrupar bien
cuando croacia después del 20 o 25
empezó a tomar protagonismo en el
partido creo que es un equipo con mucho
potencial y el partido de hoy demuestra
esa capacidad colectiva también más allá
de las individualidades
es sin duda una copa sin sorpresas hasta
el momento y creo que lo que vamos a ver
en las fases siguientes partidos muy
interesantes y sobre todo eso
entrenadores que ya han sabido potenciar
una idea muy clara en estos equipos
esto se materializa muy bien en el caso
en la tierra un grupo joven que viene
trabajando desde categoría categorías
inferiores y que tiene el mundial de
rusia tuvo un desempeño muy bueno nos
decía natalia ganó italia para mí no tan
favorita ganó bélgica y ganó en
inglaterra de momento me lo decías tú
también están cumpliendo los favoritos
lo de italia es muy interesante yo creo
que esta reconstrucción de roberto
mancini está demostrando que no son sólo
29 28 partidos invicto nueve victorias
consecutivas sino que hay una idea muy
clara
fue un equipo que siempre buscó el
partido no es una italia como en el
estilo que suele mantenerse en el
imaginario colectivo de equipos
defensivos fue un equipo que siempre
buscó con un mediocampo de mucha clase
con los niños sacando muy clara la
pelota y sobre todo con una insignia que
por la banda izquierda junto a espina
sola le hizo mucho daño al equipo rival
creo que turquía quedó en deuda después
de una fase de clasificatoria bastante
interesante en bélgica también lo vimos
a llegan al 30 es una primera parte muy
buena una segunda parte que para mí fue
un poco menos atractiva y lukaku
demostrando que es uno de los mejores
delanteros en ese momento ahí sí creo
que el rival es el que nos permite medir
muy claramente en qué nivel estaba el
ica por supuesto una de las selecciones
con una nómina muy rica doble está de
lukaku que además celebró el gol
dedicando solo a su compañero eric sehn
creo que es una selección muy
interesante tiene muchísimo talento
hazard incluso está de vuelta ayer
o kevin de bruyne entonces creo que ese
potencial es una de las grandes
favoritas es una selección que da más ha
venido trabajando muy en su proceso creo
que el técnico roberto martínez el
español está haciendo un gran trabajo
lleva trabajando muchos años con estas
selecciones del mundo el de rusia hizo
un gran papel para mí y bélgica y
francia las favoritas para este torneo
llevamos tres días de eurocopa y podemos
decir que hasta ahora los más aplaudidos
son el equipo médico eso por la
actuación de este sábado en ese partido
que vimos entre dinamarca y finlandia
nos lo decía ya también natalia erice no
está bien estar recuperándose y aplausos
para el personal médico y todo el
protocolo de actuación es el primer
campeón de esta copa américa quedó muy
claro que los protocolos en este tipo de
casos que no son habituales en el fútbol
son fundamentales desde sus jugadores el
capitán del equipo que sabía cómo actuar
en un momento como éste creo que la
situación fue bastante angustiante es
muy buena noticia que la evolucione que
esté estable y por supuesto eso tener
claro que en un torneo como éste y en
una situación de pandemia
los jugadores son el principal punto de
atención y sobre todo tener estos temas
muy claros
el fútbol en general ha aprendido mucho
desgraciadamente a través de episodios
pasados y ya hay mucha mejor preparación
para cómo reaccionar ante estas dos
paradas cardiorrespiratorias ante estos
cinco pues vamos a pasar a la copa
américa tenemos dos partidos en esta
jornada inaugural
ambos son por el grupo b brasil recibió
a venezuela en brasilia y colombia se
mide ante ecuador en cuya va y para
saber cuál es el ambiente de esta copa
américa marcada por la incertidumbre
digamos del informe desde el río de
janeiro de nuestra corresponsal
valeria saccone
arranca hoy en brasil la copa américa
entre polémicas y también bajo la sombra
de los casos de coronavirus detectados
en las elecciones de venezuela y bolivia
el país está muy divididos hay una parte
de la población que cree que si se puede
celebrar con seguridad este campeonato a
pesar de que el país está a punto de
superar los 500 mil muertos por el
coronavirus sin embargo otra parte de la
población cree que no era el momento que
no era una prioridad que brasil tiene
problemas más importantes como una
vacunación lenta en una pandemia fuera
de control y además porque hay muchos
expertos creen que está a punto de
comenzar una tercera onda que puede ser
aún más mortífera que la segunda
recordamos que después del rechazo de
argentina y de colombia el presidente
james bolsonaro decidió acoger esta
competición y que incluso el supremo
tuvo que intervenir y votar para
permitir la celebración hoy el partido
arranca a las 6 hora local en el estadio
de brasilia y se enfrentarán brasil y
venezuela- lo escuchábamos la pandemia
más presente que nunca en este comienzo
de la
la copa américa marcando el 19 el debut
de esta competición 11 casos positivos
en la selección de venezuela ocho de
ellos jugadores cuatro casos positivos
en bolivia tres de ellos jugadores y la
selección colombia acaba de confirmar
que el asistente técnico pablo román y
el fisioterapeuta carlos entrena también
son positivos por supuesto a
sintomáticos y aislados cumpliendo todo
el protocolo de conmover en los dos
casos la pandemia muy de cerca esa
noticia de colombia que yo creo que
genera mucha inquietud porque estamos
hablando del fisioterapeuta que es uno
de los que está contagiado lo decía
valeria estamos hablando casi más de la
pandemia que de la propia copa américa a
más estas últimas noticias llegan casi
que a horas antes desde el partido
inaugural sí pues venezuela tuvo que
convocar 15 jugadores nuevos y esto sin
duda influirá en el nivel del equipo que
va a competir hoy en ese partido
inaugural pero sin duda lo que hemos
visto es un apoyo generalizado por parte
de entrenadores y de los jugadores que
han asistido a las ruedas de prensa al
torneo ellos dicen que la situación es
un tema global y que la conmebol está
haciendo lo necesario para
para llevar a cabo el campeonato jose
peseiro que así el técnico de venezuela
muy afectado por la situación dijo que
van a intentar hacer en lo posible desde
la dignidad desde el colectivo entonces
vamos a ver qué partido solo sale hoy en
brasilia el propio casemiro decía en
rueda de prensa reconocemos que estamos
en una cita ante una selección que está
muy diezmada y es que vamos a ver cómo
funciona el protocolo de la conmebol que
lo que dice es que se pueden hacer
reemplazos de manera ilimitada ante lo
que hay ante los casos de contagios
frente a esa lista de 60 jugadores que
se presentó de manera inicial brasil sin
duda alguna sala yo creo que es uno de
los favoritos viene de una eliminatoria
perfecta seis de seis pero por el otro
lado los equipos venimos con mucha
incertidumbre chileno ganó a argentina
no ganó quienes son los favoritos para
esta copa américa siempre hay que hablar
de favoritos en sudamérica por la
historia brasil es el actual campeón de
la copa américa eliminatoria perfecta 9
títulos de copa américa también estaba
uruguay con 14 títulos argentina con 15
títulos que son los equipos además con
un gran número de jugadores
y también procesos más o menos estables
estamos hablando de ti te de scaloni y
por supuesto del maestro tabárez que ya
es una insignia en el fútbol
sudamericano creo que parte de esto
todos los entrenadores también han
explicado que esta copa américa va a ser
para probar sobre todo para tener un mes
de trabajo con esos equipos que por
temas de pandemia no hayan podido
entrenarse entendiendo que este es un
año previo a mundial y que las
eliminatorias son el principal objetivo
de cada una de estas selecciones si
desea ahora seguimos con la copa américa
porque hay mucha polémica en comentó
hernán as declaraciones de jamil
rodríguez que dijo en un instagram live
quiere seleccionador reinaldo rueda le
faltó el respeto por no incluirlo en la
lista de la copa américa palabras que
dijo un día antes del debut de colombia
que no han sentado muy bien en parte de
la opinión pública si es un tema
complicado porque parecía un tema
cerrado una vez que tanto el entrenador
como él ya habían dado sus comunicados
previos y se explicó que se trataba de
un tema médico él insiste en que está en
condiciones o estaba en condiciones de
asistir a la copa américa y tal vez lo
que eso cuestiona es la manera como él
elige comunicarlo el momento en el que
elige hacerlo sin
a futuro estará en manos del entrenador
reinaldo rueda volver a acercarlo en sus
términos porque lo que hizo jaime fue
agrandar un poco más esa grieta que
existe entre ambos pero si está en manos
del entrenador que empieza un proceso
que tuvo una unas jornadas de
eliminatorias positivas y que sobre todo
tiene que estar enfocado con los
jugadores que tiene en este momento
gracias ahora se nos acabó el tiempo en
diario de copas quédense porque más en
france 24 punto com
[Música]